SPEAKER 1: We're here at Google
I/O '19, and I'm Jessica.
I'm standing right in front of
the Google Assistant Sandbox,
where there's tons of cool demos
and people we could chat with.
Let's go inside.
We're inside the now, and
we're here with [INAUDIBLE]..
[INAUDIBLE],, tell me
about Google Assistant.
SPEAKER 2: Hi.
So the Google Assistant is an
AI-powered digital assistant
that is kind of your
own little assistant
with the power of Google.
And the purpose of it is to
help users get things done.
SPEAKER 1: That's awesome.
So how can users interact
with the Google Assistant?
On what mediums?
SPEAKER 2: So right now,
the Google Assistant
is available across
over 1 billion devices
and over 1,500 types of devices.
So this is everything from
voice-activated speakers,
smart displays,
wearables, headphones.
SPEAKER 1: Oh my gosh,
that's super exciting.
So here in the Sand
Dome today that we have,
what are we showing off?
SPEAKER 2: So in
this space, we're
showing different device
types that developers
can build for--
anything from voice-only
to voice and screens.
But around the
entire sandbox, we're
actually showing
new integrations
for everything for Android
developers, web and video
developers, device
developers, and
Assistant-specific developers.
SPEAKER 1: Oh my gosh,
that's super cool.
Thank you so much, [INAUDIBLE],,
for hanging out with us.
Really appreciate it.
We're here you in
the App Actions
section of the Sand Dome, and
we're here with [INAUDIBLE]..
[INAUDIBLE],, what
are app actions?
SPEAKER 3: App Actions let
you shortcut your users
into different parts
of your Android app
using the power of
the Google Assistant.
SPEAKER 1: Oh my gosh,
that sounds so exciting.
So as an Android
developer, what do I
have to do in order
to connect my Android
app to Google Assistant?
SPEAKER 3: Yeah, so the
steps are really simple.
So first, Google has these
things called built-in intents.
And what they do
is they take care
of all the natural language
understanding for you,
and they'll extract different
parameters on your behalf.
Next, all you do is create
one file called actions.xml.
And in that file, you
take different parameters
that we extract from
language for you
and you map them to
Android deep links.
Just like that, Google Assistant
can open different parts
of your app and prefill data
for users, which saves them
time and saves them taps.
SPEAKER 1: Oh my gosh,
that sounds super exciting,
especially when it comes
to not having to handle
natural language processing.
Google Assistant
handles that for you.
That's fantastic.
So can you tell me about--
how does that compare
the Android experience
compared to a voice experience?
What are the benefits
to that, for a user?
SPEAKER 3: So for a
user, it allows you
to get where you want faster.
So essentially, App
Actions is going
to save you time and effort.
So something that might
have taken 10 taps--
for example, sending
a payment to someone--
by sending things in natural
language in just one sentence,
you'll have to avoid saying who
you want to send the money to,
how much you want
to send, and so on.
SPEAKER 1: Oh, that's fantastic.
I know we have a
demo of S'mores,
and so I know there's
multiple steps.
Can you tell me a little
bit more about that?
SPEAKER 3: Yeah.
So over here we set up a demo
for a s'mores ordering app,
where you can customize a
delicious s'more, choosing
things like graham crackers,
chocolate, et cetera.
And you'll notice that going
through the entire ordering
flow takes about 10 to 15 taps.
But using App Actions, you can
try again and say something
like-- order an Oreo s'more
from the S'mores app--
and it takes you straight to
the final screen without having
to go through the full ordering
flow, saving you time and taps.
SPEAKER 1: Oh my gosh, I could
definitely see for the users
this being really exciting.
And then for
developers, this just
means that users are more likely
to come back to their Android
app, which is great.
Thank you so much for
hanging out with us.
Really appreciate it.
So we're here in the [INAUDIBLE]
section for how-to guides,
and I'm here with [? Eileen. ?]
[? Eileen, ?] can you tell me
all about this space?
SPEAKER 4: This space is
for content creators who
wants to bring rich experiences
for Search and Assistant
by using structured
data program.
And we have two methods of
building structured data.
One is web markup, and then
the other is templates.
SPEAKER 1: That's exciting.
So if I'm a developer,
and I have a website,
and I have content on there,
how can I connect that content
to Google Assistant?
SPEAKER 4: Great question.
So basically, all you need
to do is to use a web markup
and structure your content, and
you would get rich experiences
on Search and Assistant.
And specifically for how-to,
we are so happy to announce
our support of [? how ?]
[? to ?] [? structure ?]
[? data ?] program as of
yesterday at I/O. And now,
as a web developer, you can go
ahead and mark up your website
with text, images, and videos,
and get these rich experiences
on Search and the Assistant.
SPEAKER 1: Oh my gosh.
So you do this
markup language once,
and it's available not
just on the system,
but you get rich
displays on Search too?
SPEAKER 4: Exactly.
SPEAKER 1: That's fantastic.
So what if I'm a content
provider or creator
and I don't have
access to my website,
or I have a YouTube
video and I want
to connect all that information
to Google Assistant,
can that happen?
SPEAKER 4: Yes, actually.
Amazing question.
For that, we have a
solution for templates.
So specifically, for
the how-to tutorials,
we build a how-to
video template.
If you maintain your
content mostly on YouTube,
you can come and fill
in basic spreadsheet.
By following the actions
in Google how-to template,
you can put your YouTube URL,
anchor it by the timestamp,
add the steps, and
out of the box,
you would get to rich
Assistant action experiences.
SPEAKER 1: That's great.
And so do I have to worry about
the natural language processing
when it comes to this, or does
Google handle that for me?
SPEAKER 4: Actually,
Google handles it for you.
Both for markup
and the templates,
we take care of natural
language understanding,
and also, we handle the
discovery of your content.
You don't need to worry about
anything like NLU or anything
to do with machine learning.
SPEAKER 1: That's great.
And can you tell me
a little bit more
about the demo that
we have here today?
SPEAKER 4: Sure, of course.
So for the demo today, we
built a sample websites,
how to make an origami.
For the first method,
we created the website
and we marked it up, and
for the second method,
we built a YouTube video
and created a spreadsheet.
So all the users have to
do is naturally ask how
to make origami,
and they would get
these rich experiences without
doing any additional custom
work.
And users can engage with
this in a system with voice
interactions, and this gives
you out-of-the-box speech
recognition.
SPEAKER 1: That's fantastic.
Thank you so much, [? Eileen, ?]
for hanging out with us.
Really appreciate it.
SPEAKER 4: Thank you
so much, Jessica.
SPEAKER 1: OK, let's keep going.
We're at the Interactive
Canvas section of the Dome,
and I'm here with Jacob.
Jacob, can you tell me
more about this space?
SPEAKER 5: Yeah, absolutely.
So Interactive Canvas is
a powerful new developer
capability that lets
our developers get
full control over
what they're putting
on the screen of the device.
You can do this using
existing web technologies,
and we think it's really
great for building games
for the Assistant.
SPEAKER 1: OK, when you say
existing web technologies,
what type of tools
are we talking about?
SPEAKER 5: Absolutely.
So anything that you have
used on the web before--
[INAUDIBLE] any high-level
frameworks, like Angular--
all of that works here.
So if you've built
anything on the web,
you'll feel right at
home building for Canvas.
SPEAKER 1: That
is super exciting.
So if I already have
an Action, and it's
all about playing games,
can I add this onto that?
SPEAKER 5: Absolutely.
So you can think of Interactive
Canvas as a visual layer
on top of your
conversation Actions.
So to incorporate it,
it's just a matter
of adding another
type of response
in your existing webhook.
SPEAKER 1: All right.
And when it comes to designing
this, is this just touch only,
is this voice, is
it a combination?
What's the goal of this?
SPEAKER 5: Yeah, so as you
may have seen in the demo,
it offers really rich visual
experiences to our users.
And we're really excited
to see what you can build,
in terms of combining both voice
and touch into your Actions.
SPEAKER 1: Awesome.
Can you tell me more
about this specific demo?
Because it's all jungle-themed,
and seems really exciting.
Can you tell me more
about the design?
SPEAKER 5: Yeah, absolutely.
So we built this game
to showcase all the fun
things you can use
Canvas for, and we did it
in the context of a
jungle-themed adventure game.
So you go through the jungle.
You're trying to navigate
through this temple
and escape eventually.
But it all turns out it
was a dream all along.
SPEAKER 1: Oh my gosh,
that's super exciting.
Well, Jacob, thank you so
much for hanging out with us.
Really appreciate it.
SPEAKER 5: Thank you so much.
SPEAKER 1: OK, let's keep going.
So we're here in the
Local Home SDK section,
and I'm here with Carl.
Carl, can you tell
me about this space?
SPEAKER 6: Sure.
So this is the
Local Home SDK area,
and we're showing a
visual representation
of the life of a local
query using the local home
SDK versus the normal cloud
query with the smart home API.
SPEAKER 1: So what's
different for developers
when it comes to the local
SDK compared to before?
SPEAKER 6: Great question.
So with the smart
home API, that's
the primary way developers
integrate their smart devices
to the Google Assistant.
And that's a
cloud-to-cloud integration.
Where after a system
processes that command,
we send it to the
developer to, ultimately,
fulfill it to the end device.
With the local home
SDK, now we give them
the ability to do that
same fulfillment over
on the user's
local area network,
providing huge increases
in speed and reliability.
SPEAKER 1: Oh my gosh.
I can definitely see from
the user's perspective,
it'd be a lot faster, right?
SPEAKER 6: Totally.
Yeah, because now we don't
need to go to multiple clouds.
We can do this a lot faster
on the local network.
SPEAKER 1: OK, Carl.
Can you show us a demo?
SPEAKER 6: Absolutely.
So this train
represents the life
of a local query and
this train represents
the one that goes from the
cloud-to-cloud integration
using the smart home API.
So what we see happens is
when a user says a command.
For example, turn on the lights.
Both go to the
Assistant server to be
processed in the same way.
But if we know the device
is locally controllable,
we then send that JSON payload
back down to the Google Home
device where we pull
up the developers
JavaScript to process it,
and ultimately fulfill it.
And there it is.
The light is on.
And what we see with
the other train is it
the cloud-to-cloud
integration still works.
However, it just takes longer
to get to the same point.
So this really demonstrates
the increase in speed
that we can get with
the local home SDK.
SPEAKER 1: Oh my gosh.
That's awesome, Carl.
Thank you so much.
That was really cool.
Thanks for chatting with us.
SPEAKER 6: Thanks for coming by.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
Let's keep going.
We're at the Smart Home section
and I'm talking to [? Omar. ?]
[? Omar, ?] can you tell
me about this space?
SPEAKER 7: Yeah, absolutely.
So what we're
showcasing over here
is the new functionality
that we have come out
with for our partners to
utilize to enable an Assistant
experience for their products.
SPEAKER 1: So this is all
about marrying kind of hardware
and Google Assistant, right?
SPEAKER 7: Absolutely.
So this is about us being
able to-- or as a user,
being able to control
the devices that we
use on a daily basis
in our households.
SPEAKER 1: And so if
I'm a hardware developer
and I have this stuff, how do
I connect my hardware to Google
Assistant?
What things should
I keep in mind?
SPEAKER 7: Definitely.
So what we have is
we have device types
and we have traits.
Right.
So you can think about
it from the perspective
of a light bulb.
A light bulb is the identity of
the device, which is the type.
And you have traits,
which is functionality
for that light bulb.
You have brightness.
You have on/off.
You have color.
Once you marry the
two together, you
have a fairly robust product.
So what we're asking
our developers to do
is bring certain hardware that
enables certain functionality
like that.
And then using the traits
that we've offered,
create an Assistant
experience around it.
SPEAKER 1: That's awesome.
But as a hardware developer
as I connect everything,
do I have to worry about
how the user is going
to interact with my action or is
that something Google Assistant
handles for me?
SPEAKER 7: The Google Assistant
will handle that for the user.
As new languages are supported,
as new locales are enabled,
all of that is inherited as
part of the smart home track.
Which is the great
thing about it.
SPEAKER 1: Oh my gosh.
I know we have a cookie demo
here and I have a sweet tooth.
So I'd love for you to talk
more about the cookie demo.
SPEAKER 7: Absolutely.
The cookie demo has actually
been very popular today.
But what we're trying
to showcase with this
is a very key feature, which
is two-factor authentication.
Now two-factor
authentication is really
needed for security devices
like doors, garage doors.
Anything that could
be a security thing
needs to have this additional
layer of security on top of it.
And what we do is we
give you the ability
to add 2FA to any type of
trait that you've implemented.
SPEAKER 1: That's amazing.
Well thank you so
much, [? Omar. ?] I
really appreciate you
sharing all this with us.
SPEAKER 7: Absolutely.
Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: Oh my gosh.
That was amazing.
If you're excited like
me to start building
for Google Assistant,
check out our docs
and I'm looking forward to
seeing you guys next year.
[MUSIC PLAYING]